[Music]
it's starting at zero but oh
hey that's us um what's up guys welcome
back to culture bench this is the white
crack podcast
where we explore the ins and outs of the
cultural zeitgeist i'm michael burns
joined as always
by the guy who refuses to let me start a
wisecrack company softball team because
it's
non-union alec opperman alec how are you
today
i'm great how are you all pretty good um
i'm also joined by the person
who gave me the kind of sus advice that
it was totally fine to wear a tie-dye
tank top to a meeting with a group of
corporate executives
serbia serbia was bad advice but how are
you today i'm well thanks how are you
pretty good although i did not sell my
product
to apple um but i'm excited to be here
with you all as always um if anyone who
is lucky enough to be watching this on
video you're seeing that alec has a
really cool shirt on today so uh maybe
when you're done listening to the
podcast go back and
find the video so you can see it is that
okay that i'm shouting out your fashion
yeah that's fine awesome um so we have a
lot to talk about today um we are gonna
get
some some analysis and thoughts from
serbia on the new business casual a
bunch of people are going back to the
office so let's make sure you do it
right
um alec this is a huge one guys you're
talking about sports today
i'm a sportsman yeah we got a sportsman
today
um and i'm gonna talk about critical
race theory because i just want to get
in trouble
so i i threw a dart at a problematic and
hot button topics and that's what came
up but first
the most controversial thing of them all
slaps and chaps
um we'll talk about what we're like and
and maybe not liking since we were last
together
serbia let's start with you what are
your slaps and chaps this go around
so what slaps right now uh so many
wonderful professional opportunities are
coming to my friends and i'm super super
happy about that
amazing um yeah a lot of uh new roles a
lot of promotions
and uh what's even more exciting is that
they're all women
and i love it when uh when women are in
business are in leadership roles and i'm
especially pleased when it's my friends
so it's great to see them become ceos
founders
directors vps all of that um
also i just finished the second season
of lupon on netflix
and it was fantastic and i'm looking
forward to season three
whenever that films and is released
and that's the the french heist show yes
it's so good awesome
okay it's good here i saw i i see people
that like that i saw some people
uh tweeting their feelings about season
two so we're glad to know it as a
serbian stamp of approval
yeah um wait was there a chap
involved were those two my chap um
so on the other hand uh speaking of my
friends my
uh friend's dad passed away a couple
weeks ago yeah it's really sad
and i don't have a lot of experience
with
uh death and grief so
um i i'm trying to be super supportive
and very kind and uh caring towards her
and i sent her flowers and penis cookies
um sorry did you say did you say peanut
cookies or
penis cookies penis penis shaped
cookie inappropriate brief gift yes
i thought it would make her smile and
she thought it was perfect um her mom
loved it as well
and it was it was fabulous it was very
highly detailed it was by it's uh made
by a bakery in san francisco called
hot cookie uh highly recommend if you're
in the mood for a penis-shaped cookie
there are also cookies available um if
someone would have sent me those after
my parent passed away i would have loved
that i mean that kind of genuinely it
would have put a smile on my face
yeah it would have been fun and i would
have thought this is great that this
friend
isn't like overdoing it but is reminding
me of of
joy and frivolity in life so i think
that's a really cool thing to do but if
you're listening just be
much better than thoughts and prayers
don't send thoughts and prayers send
dicks and bags i don't know if it's like
a match took some
cookies yeah match cookies those looked
good too and they have like rainbow
sprinkles and very strategic places i
loved it
wow that's really fun yeah so so if
anybody has any advice on
uh how to um what anything that
like if you've gone through a situation
like this what what was um
what what helped you the most or what
did you appreciate the most please let
me know because i
i feel so sad and so helpless and i i
want to cheer her up
i'll jump in real quick just to say when
i when i had a parent pass away the
thing that i really liked what my
friends did this doesn't sound very
vague but just like
being there and asking me to do normal
stuff
because there's this period where
someone passes away and everyone treats
you like you're different and it starts
to feel weird and you get kind of mad
about it
so i remember the first time like a
friend just like asked to hang out and
do normal stuff
it felt really good but of course yeah i
don't know and i think there's something
about that that it
feels weird because in our heads we're
like i can't be normal you just went
through this
traumatic thing what am i going to do
just be like do you want to eat a hot
dog and watch sports but that's what
they want to do they might not want to
do that but you know what i'm saying
okay so yeah thank you but that's really
cool and it's even
even thinking about that shows that
you're such a good friend that you're
you're
you know wanting to do the right thing
that's incredible that's so nice thank
you for saying that
yeah um but don't take alex advices
would be to be
really always awful my advice isn't
sometimes mean but not often
i'm kidding i'm kidding um so alec how
about you what's what are your slaps
and i'll i'll say potential chaps
because you are the bad boy of the
podcast who refuses to play by the rules
and normally just
sticks with toxic positivity and
piercings i'm really late to the game
but i did watch i think you should leave
or a few episodes and it's
just watched it i'm like four episodes
in maybe
oh yeah uh it's it's delightful i'm so
excited there's a season two
um i will i will cede my chaps time to
dudabods who commented
uh just caught me donating just caught
me mid donating plasma
slaps work slaps work is good chaps the
long hours due to employee shortages in
service industries
congrats for donating plasma donate
plasma donate blood donate bone marrow
just
basically donate everything you don't
need donate everything um that's awesome
also special shout outs to dubai to
was in the chat and donated during our
first um squanch live recording but i
just wasn't looking at the chat so i
didn't see it till after the fact and i
thought i hope
abides knows that he's loved and valued
and not being ignored
yeah dude is part of the culture binge
and greater wisecrack family for sure
yeah if you come for dude abides we'll
will ruin your life
and make you wish you're interested in
penis cookies and never you'll never get
a penis
cookie in your in your gotch darn life
um were any chaps for you alec are you
staying positive with your positive stay
positive
awesome um i'll also go very simple and
tv based for my slap
um i'm liking loki um you know all these
mcu shows have had a lot of hype around
them
i've gotten caught up in the hype and i
have for the previous two
mcu shows one division and falconry
soldier started real hot by the end was
kind of like eh
i'm liking loki i think it's going to be
good and also let's let's let's get owen
wilson back in
in the rotation of people who are in
things god it's great to hang out with
an owen wilson character
i think he's in the upcoming west
anderson film so i'm excited about that
as well
um chaps this will be like slightly i
guess personal
as as serbies was guys never never plan
a wedding
never get married never do anything it's
so complicated and so difficult
and i i had an experience of on choosing
to not invite some family members who i
might just haven't been close with for
years and i thought it wouldn't be a big
deal
it was a big deal and i've had to deal
with the fallout
and it's just rough it's such a rough
thing
and people's expectations around
weddings are so weird and i have this
naive brain that says oh
it's simply about me and my partner and
a celebration of our love and everyone
else gets that
they know it's not about them they don't
get that they all think it's about them
so if you go down this path friends just
be wary
yeah yeah sorry i i had to vent that uh
to my friends
uh my friends survey alec and dudabites
um so before we get into it oh sorry
serbia you look like red say something
oh yeah so how are you navigating it are
you just giving in or
are you no me giving i i double down
uh to my own detriment it's the story of
my life um i have had to
have some conversations with some people
who i think
whose feelings were hurt and try to like
explain some stuff so i have been like
i haven't changed my position but i've
been like
hey i understand how this might have
hurt your feelings here's where i'm
coming from
let me buy you a drink sometime it's
weird for me because i have one side of
my family where i have like 30 something
cousins
so it's normal on that side of the
family that everyone's not invited to
everything because you simply couldn't
do it
but this other side of the family very
small they're like
we should all be at things because we're
small and i didn't really realize that
so um
but also but aren't there i'm not sure
if there are but are there any like
uh attendance restrictions due to the
um uh we're getting married in the state
of illinois
as of right now um when we're getting
married in the winter in the state of
illinois assuming the delta variant
doesn't
wreck our society in the fabric of our
social life
um we should be at a number that's okay
and we are we are going to
request that everyone is vaxed up uh see
so like if
you still have the attendance
restrictions you could have been like
i'm sorry
like we're limited in number well the
one move that i thought would work but
doesn't if you tell people
you know we just want it to be like a
casual fun thing so we're trying to keep
numbers low they're like yeah yeah yeah
but why am i not there
i want to come to the casual fun thing
yeah just you know what just don't
everyone just the lope find a nice place
somewhere pretty and just the lope um
you know alec if you ever go down that
path i just think it goes nice
outdoors get your partner on the podcast
let's talk about this right now we'll do
that for the second segment
um but before i make alec uncomfortable
and potentially cause problems in his
relationship
quick reminder um if you enjoyed this
podcast and honestly even if you only
kind of enjoy it
please subscribe on whatever platform
you use to listen to this podcast
um you could you could do that on
spotify itunes stitcher
uh wherever you see it or you could you
know obviously subscribe to the wisecast
channels
if this is how you check it out and then
please rate and review we love to get
good ratings and reviews and we in
particular like if the reviews are fun
if we get fun reviews
we will read them as we often do i think
there might have even been an email
between
since the last episode where someone
else does the game or they say what we
all are in a certain categorization of
things
so do that we like it and it honestly
means a lot to us so
do that if you get a chance but now
let's get into the the
main course of our meal serbia get us
started um
talk to us about what people are wearing
as they go back to work
and the changing rules of these things
so
i'm super interested in
this return to work because we most of
us have been working remotely or many of
us have been
working remotely and uh it's
nice to see like how things are changing
as a result of the pandemic
um and i
read this article recently or it was
like a linkedin post
um this man has these uh
tattoos on his face
and i i
can't remember the exact words of this
post but the
general uh feeling was that
um he feels that having this tattoo
oh i gotta i gotta get out of this
um having the having the tattoo hasn't
impacted his um work at all or his
ability to find work
um and i'm wondering if there's
more of that now because i work at a
remote company
and people have tattoos like full
sleeves tattoos on their chest their
neck whatever
um they have different like interesting
hairstyles or they have like pink hair
mohawks whatever they want to do and
nobody cares
um and i'm wondering if now that we've
all been at home
for a year many of us have been at home
for a year if this return to work
will uh result in any changes will
people be
less willing to cover up their tattoos
or maybe they want to experiment with
different hairstyles or different like
hair dye
um also i don't know about
everyone else but i've been wearing
exclusively i've been exclusively
wearing loungewear for the past year
um so does anyone else not want to get
back
into like professional attire or like a
pair of jeans
um i wore jeans maybe 10 times during
during lockdown and it was extremely
uncomfortable probably because i gained
15 pounds over the last year
but also because jeans just aren't great
so
i'm yeah i got the stretch jeans
they're stretched jeans yeah they're
they're not full stretch like it's a
it's a mix of the denim and some sort of
stretchy material
uh they're great they're much more comfy
and
uh they're better at like being sort of
like moving around and being active
yeah i have some of those from a company
that i guess we're not supposed to buy
stuff from anymore i forget what's okay
and what's not okay but yeah
they're nice in that sense because you
can fluctuate a little bit as i tend to
do seasonally
i respond yeah i've been wearing normal
jeans um
yeah i literally have to unbutton my
pants like when i sit down
oh well so we're gonna start it's like
the blazer thing you know you sit down
you unbutton the blazer you sit back up
you button back up but yeah
it's the the jeans version and yeah
that's it yeah
i forget to button them when i stand
back up and so i kind of like tend to
walk around like a five-year-old you
know with like a
little belly hanging out nice but i i
feel that general struggle i've spent
much of the past year wearing gym shorts
around the house like i'm a middle
schooler
class you're wearing gym shorts with
that cool shirt yeah i mean
when i go out later today i will put on
respectable
clothing but it's gym shorts man okay
you a man who can do both
um but that's interesting i mean serbia
i think
what this makes me think of is like i
wonder if
like the the situation learned right now
is going to help lead the way for a
cultural shift in like workplace
attire and aesthetics because it really
does feel like a previous generation
that established all of these norms in
workplace culture and i know that for a
lot of
like millennials and gen z types those
norms haven't been ingrained in the
culture the same way
so i wonder if in a sense like in a good
way maybe
not to use a bad thing in a good way but
like thinking of naomi klein's like
shock doctrine logic if this could be
like a a tire based shock doctrine
where the crazy thing that's happened in
the world could help
initiate a new framework where people
don't have to worry about that stuff
and and can get a job if they have
tattoos or piercings or things like that
but then i also wonder is someone who's
never really worked in a
what would you call it moneyed industry
if
if you're working in like finance or law
or whatever it's still the same and
you're expected to look like don draper
yeah i i feel like there's certainly a
bias
probably among the three of us in that
in new york
and maybe excluding like financial or
lawyers like those industries
nobody gives a [ __ ] in new york you see
so many different kinds of people
it's not shocking or weird at all to see
someone with purple hair
or to have a ton of tattoos and so i
think that bleeds over professionally
that being said i'm sure there will be
loosenings of restrictions um especially
like as bosses basically beg their
employees to come back into work and not
quit
uh i mentioned this last podcast but
there's uh this book coffee land that uh
talks about world war ii specifically
where you know because of the war
there's all these worker shortages
uh and that's where the coffee break
came in because they're like
uh we have to hire like not like these
young men we're gonna hire
you know maybe some older people maybe
some women
and to basically stop themselves from
exhausting themselves with factory work
we're gonna
you know give them 15 minutes to drink a
cup of coffee twice a day and then after
the war was over
they just basically were like no we're
doing this for now on and that sort of
like instituted
our break culture uh or a lot of our
brake culture
and i think you know not with coffee
obviously but i feel like similar things
might happen with covid where
stretched a little bit we've sort of
gotten a lot of leniency in some areas
and people might be like
no i'm not i'm not wearing some like
really
stuffy uncomfortable dress shirt yeah i
think that's a good like general point
as well even with
beyond just a tire like so many norms
have changed in the past year
on both sides like in terms of
expectations of employers and
expectations from employees and it'll be
interesting to see like what shifts back
and what changes
are permanent because even things like
flexible working schedules it seems like
a lot of companies
are saying like okay if you've been
getting your stuff done in this way
that's awesome but it seems like some
are saying nope
gotta come back into the office no more
uh lockdown work from home sweatpants
stuff
yeah it's really interesting to me that
a lot of companies
require you to sit in your chair from
like eight to six
or nine to five or whatever hours you
work like if you're done with your work
at 12
you can't leave and i've worked in
office where people have been like
no but you're just gonna leave right now
at twelve like you should be here in
case we need you
so i'd literally have to sit there until
five
even if i had nothing else to do what's
that like indentured logic in the sense
where like you have to be there
like those 40 hours or whatever the
company owns you
so you have to be there so even if you
finish your work which creates that like
really
unhealthy work culture in some cases of
people that just like [ __ ] around on
their computer for three hours
even though they're done with their work
because they're not allowed to leave
yeah i wonder if that will change as
well like people will now say like no
i'm done
and there will be the workforce will
demand
flexible working hours or will just be
more forceful
in saying i'm done with my work measure
my results
not the hours that i work and get them
done i don't think we're ready to be
that brazen about it but i think people
will
be like i'm gonna work from home with
the implicit understanding that like
if i finish by three i'll respond to
your slack messages but i'm not gonna
sit around and pretend to work you know
yeah i think that is like the
i don't want to say the sad state of
affairs cause like it is what it is and
i think there's
in many areas of society we sort of have
like not open
lies but things that we know but you
just like can't say that everyone knows
i think it will be like that for a while
i think that maybe and i don't i hope
this doesn't veer off your topic too
much serbia because
it's a great topic but i do wonder if
this leads into stuff like
along with all the entire stuff does the
past year help us get closer to
something like a four-day work week or
companies experimenting with stuff like
that i saw that on
yesterday there's a i'm forgetting name
of there's a research group
um in the uk that's trying to advocate
for a four-day work week and they put
out a huge poll in the uk and it was
like
63 or 70 percent of people were all for
that
um obviously a lot of companies have
already tried that out so i will be
curious to see if along with the tire
stuff
there is any like formal experimentation
with work hours and structure
that would be really interesting um
i i i'm not sure if this is real i saw
it when i was going to sleep but it was
like a
there was a headline about japan
experiment or thinking about it and i
was like really
japan might be doing a four-day work
week that's that would be
amazing um just because the for those of
you don't know the japanese business
culture is quite intense
so the idea of uh of
there being a shift towards working
fewer hours would be quite significant
um i also am curious i read this article
that said
um most people would rather
quit than go back to work in the office
full-time yeah um
and i'm i 100 agree with that i feel
like it's a slow death working in the
office but i know that
hot take i want to be in an office at
least once a week twice a week
i've been working from home for four to
five years
and sometimes it's just nice to see a
human who's not living with you
i i agree this is where i'm also a freak
this has been my first
full year working from home and i i
cannot say enough how much i hate it
um i like my house to be a place where i
just like hang out and my brain is like
oh
you're at home you can just do chill
stuff i'm not like oh you're at home
do work stuff and there is something
about like being in a place around
other people i don't know having a space
that's like neutral
to be in i don't know i i wouldn't mind
a world where offices have more of like
a casual thing where you have some sort
of like
open working space coming when you need
to you know
some decent snacks and carbonated
beverages maybe not too crazy
um but you know some some stuff to mix
it up a little bit
because i just feel like if like it
shifts to a full work from home thing
that seems dangerous because then it
becomes like no distinction between
labor and life and we're always working
a little bit and that sort of stuff
you're also like carving out a portion
of your apartment
you know like for a workspace so you're
basically paying
your rent paying the rent of an office
for yourself for your boss
so there are some startups that are
starting to provide like uh i mean
i agree with everything you both are
saying i think you have valid points um
there an emerging trend that i've seen
is that uh some startups are starting to
offer a home
office stipend um because
for those of you who don't know if you
work from home you're no longer allowed
to in the united states you're not
no longer allowed to um receive
any sort of deduction or uh the word is
escaping me but you can't receive a tax
break
um if uh you work from home before you
could
claim things like utilities and things
like that but you can't do that anymore
um and so some startups are starting to
offer
like i can't remember how much it is but
like i think it was like one article i
saw was like 500
um dollars every month um
to cover to cover expenses and i think
that is a move towards
recognizing that that it is a bit of a
financial burden to
to work from home because we're using
our utilities
our water our everything um
to be at home so um
i was going somewhere with us but but
maybe no yeah
more companies could do that it could
offset those those costs
um but i i also have heard of places
startups having like
hubs um where you can like come as you
come and go as you'd like as you were
mentioning burns
so that could be something interesting i
could see the appeal of doing something
like that especially if i was traveling
around the world it would be nice to go
to like the
paris hub or whatever and work with
people there foreign
no but like right before the pandemic
got kicked in there was a thing that
started in los angeles that i was really
curious about where a a place i like um
i'll just say what it's called the lodge
room in highland park it's like a music
venue
um it has a restaurant but you know only
open at night and they started this
thing where during the day
they left this very like cute restaurant
cafe space open
and if you paid like a membership you
could just go hang out coffee tea and
beverages
um some snacks wi-fi all that [ __ ] it
was like a pretty low fee to be like a
member there
and i was kind of like that would
actually sound kind of cool a place
where i could go whenever
it's like a cool looking space have
coffee and tea or whatever and then they
were doing like a happy hour so the end
of the day you get like a cocktail or
whatever
but it stopped because it was like when
the pandemic picked up but stuff like
that i was like okay
not like weworky stuff because i watch
that documentary and that place is us
um but you know more like chill local
stuff would be cool
especially for coffee shops to fight the
the people that sit there all day
i went my local coffee shop that just
reopened in person for the first time
yesterday
and they had a little sign on the tables
that are like hey guys we're just like
getting back to it and capacity is
limited so like
maybe think about getting up from your
table when you finish your drink
um and i like the subtle like don't sit
here all day this isn't your office
thing i like the assault on customers
yeah
yeah so i will never be going there
again i'm kidding um
so real quick before we move on to our
topics what's everyone's ideal work
outfit like what what if you could wear
whatever you wanted
that you feel and i want to be clear
here i'm not saying most comfortable
because for some people if you go too
comfortable you're not going to be
productive because then you might feel
too cozy
so we'll start with alec ideal work
attire
black t-shirt you see me on this podcast
wearing one all the time
and some shorts yeah
uh serbia how about you ideal work
outfit so i have
a work from home uniform i have 10 black
shirts
10 black pants um my serbie jobs
it's only because they were on sale um
there would be a server at a restaurant
um so the pants are great because they
have like an elastic waistline
um as i mentioned earlier i have issues
with the button
um so that's great and i
i like things that are very very soft um
i have an issue with like
textures and like the way things like
feel on my body
um and so things have to be super soft
and then i also have like five
designated
sweaters that i only wear while i'm
working
i like that yeah i'm kind of halfway
between y'all um
it's weird to say this now because it's
getting hot where i live but i think my
ideal work from home thing is a pair of
like structured shorts not gym shorts
something yeah structure i need
structure yeah i need to feel structured
there
but then i want to be wearing a soft
hoodie um because i like sometimes if
i'm working it to be a little chilly
like to pull the hood up and kind of
feel like i'm i'm in this little zone
when i'm
focusing on stuff i think that's my
ideal work thing i want to revise my
answer i want to mr robot it like you
yes um for me i mean that's i don't want
to outright say it for me
yes being hacker man is my ideal thing
so um you know guys later if you're in
the chat let us know what your ideal
work outfit would be
now monumentous occasion today for many
reasons um
because we're all together and that's
great serbia has a really cool coffee
cup i like the aesthetics of it
nice little color palette but guys alec
is going to talk
about sports this is big for me i feel
like i'm the weirdo that's occasionally
brought up
professional athletics on this podcast
i've almost been fired for it multiple
times
corporate is called down very pissed but
alec
talk to us about athletics today uh
yeah so the ncaa
is an organization for college athletes
for those who don't know
um they don't pay their students in fact
it is against the rules for them to make
any money
for people in college basketball college
football to make any money
um and even to the extent that
formally there were caps on how much
like educational payment they could get
so
traditionally they get some tuition back
et cetera et cetera but there were
limits uh
according to a unanimous decision by the
supreme court uh
those caps have been lifted the fact
that this is unanimous
is crazy to me um i'm i'm basing all
this off of a
buzzfeed news article by uh sarah mims
this is this is from the article the
decision doesn't mean that ncaa athletes
will start drawing salaries for playing
nor will affect the ongoing battle
other over whether players can profit
off of their own names or likenesses but
it will mean that schools can do a lot
more to attract and compensate students
who play
ncaa division 1 basketball and football
though the decision is narrow it's a
significant step for advocates who have
pushed to compensate ncaa
student athletes it goes on to say the
decision will mean that schools can
compensate athletes not just with
scholarships to pay
for the cost of attendance that's
already allowed but also pay for things
like computers musical instruments
graduate programs and other education
related costs schools will also be
allowed to pay
for student athletes study abroad
programs offer other scholarships and
fund internships after they've finished
playing
for the school i like musical
instruments i'm sure this is what i mean
by just imagine like come play football
for us we'll give you
like the signed eric clapton guitar
that he played with cream at wow
didn't play i don't think they played
woodstock but he did play with cream
yeah um so uh
it's a it's a little incredible to me
because uh
as someone not interested in sports i'm
kind of interested in the legal aspects
of sports and a lot of it
basically seems like insanity to me for
instance
years and years ago there's a supreme
court case about professional baseball
where the supreme court
said hey monopolies are illegal uh
baseball might be a monopoly because the
players you know as employees can't
choose
where they work for they get traded
around uh but baseball is a national
pass time and so we're going to call it
an acceptable monopoly and that's just
straight up
supreme court said uh it's magical it's
american it's okay to treat your
employees like [ __ ]
um similarly there's been uh court cases
with the ncaa over things like
people playing in the 70s or 80s or 90s
20 30 40 years later
their faces are appearing in uh like
xbox games uh and they're not making any
money for it and they're not students
anymore but they can't get paid jack
[ __ ]
uh and you know college coaches are
making millions of dollars and
you know uh schools are bringing
millions of dollars and they like to
paint it as oh it's good for the school
brings in all this money
but it just seems like a self-sustaining
infrastructure of
sports itself that enriches them and
doesn't seem to enrich
you know the actual students um
so i thought it was really interesting
um
before we get your thoughts one sort of
thing i
wanted to talk specifically about is
this idea that i don't understand at all
and perhaps you can explain it to me
burns but the ncaa's defense
is that uh well there's a quote from the
article
the ncaa felt the case in the name of
amateurism arguing that not paying
students is what makes the players
amateurs and distinguishes college
sports from professional sports and
makes it popular
essentially their argument boiled down
to americans love watching college
basketball and football in part because
the players are not paid
at one point leading justice brett
kavanaugh to say
um to pay no salaries to workers who are
making schools billions of dollars on
the theory that consumers want schools
to pay their workers nothing
that seems entirely circular and
somewhat disturbing
uh justice clarets thomas said he
thought was odd that coach's salaries
have ballooned given that amateurs
that they are amateurs just like the
players and kavanaugh
back to kavanaugh said uh it was
basically like people going to
restaurants because they like that the
chefs are not paid
um oh why do i have to agree with
something brett kavanaugh said
i mean it's a unanimous decision which i
find
you know good good for them but yeah i
mean i i i think
the amateur argument to me has always
been weird because i i think people
compare it to like are like oh
you know we've seen it musicians get
popular they get famous they start doing
it for them
the the the money and then you know they
sell out like they their their music
isn't as good
but like what does selling out look like
in a [ __ ] basketball game like i'm
only gonna
like dunk this basketball so i can get
more money no you're still trying to
[ __ ] win like
i'm not saying it's not like there's not
artistry to it in that way but the
artistry is completely different than
like
a creative thing where it is possible to
sell out yeah well those analogies are
good because think about if in any other
industry there was a
multi-billion dollar industry that made
universities
individually millions of dollars let
them sell sponsorship deals
coach and most if you look at the
highest paid state employee in most
states
it's a football coach yeah because in
most states the highest paid state
employee is the coach of the big
football team from state university
um you know any other industry that had
this much money involved
and then you said the people who produce
the product
are unpaid laborers and then you know
people historically have said like well
you know they get a college education
well and most of these in most of these
cases especially if you're a division
one let's say like basketball or
football player
you're not you don't have time to be
that committed to your academics and
that's not even your fault because they
put so many requirements on you
um in terms of athletics they give you
these little stipends but there's been
some really
kind of sad stories over the years about
collegiate athletes
who like can barely afford to eat yeah
and we have to like borrow money just
for basic life essentials
because a lot of them don't come from
money and you also and like can't take
out extra loans in a lot of cases on top
of what they're already doing can't work
other jobs because when would you have
time between a full-time student and
essentially a full-time athlete
and i do think like i think in a perfect
world colleges wouldn't have sports we
would just have
you know
but you know it's like in europe if you
are a really good soccer
for our european and non-american fans
football player
um you know you can join a team at 16 17
years old
play in a lower league work your way up
so at least you're like making an income
doing the thing you're eventually going
to do
and it would be so much better and this
is this is starting to happen in
basketball where players are either
going to play overseas after high school
or joining the nba g-league the g-league
is the developmental league that got
recently sponsored by gatorade so is now
the g-league
wow um real thing but like
that would make more sense but if these
colleges are going to make
millions and millions of dollars off
these athletes like
do some whether it's like taking a share
of the money raised and putting it in
some account that they get when they
graduate i don't even like that
but i'm just thinking like they have to
do something because it's
ridiculous um the amount of money that's
produced off
unpaid labor but do you want like i i
can't even fathom
this whole and i've heard it for years
and years and years
i like college sports better because you
know they're not doing it for the money
i can't even fathom it because it
doesn't make sense to me i'm like
you're you're playing as you know it's
this fetishization of
of athletics tying into some pure
expression of humanity and like
competition
camaraderie teamwork and these are these
core values
sorry but it makes no sense and often it
is
older men who have good jobs who
fetishize
young men who don't get paid to do these
things and you know you have the
history of the olympics as well where
for so many years to compete in the
olympics you had to be an amateur
yeah it was only kind of recently the
professional athletes started getting to
play in certain sports
in the olympics like it's really
problematic and i can't see
any good reason to say that it's
better or or or anything because of that
and like they're not in it for the love
of the game i'm sure they love the game
you're playing in college so that you
can play professionally
ideally yeah the amateur thing doesn't
make like i
like if it's the olympics where it's
like hey these are just people who
[ __ ] swim as a hobby like let's watch
them compete that's cool
but college basketball is
professionalized they just don't get
paid
you know like yeah
so sorry sir what do you think um i
i think the whole thing is just [ __ ]
dumb um
i i'm very curious um
i i know that a lot of i think i i feel
like i've
uh seen a lot of um college athletes
speak out about this
but um it makes me wonder how do you
continue like for me if i if i heard the
um ncaa's argument that uh
we're amateurs and we shouldn't be
compensated
because of that
i think i would be so [ __ ] mad and so
bitter about the whole thing
like i would i just don't know that i
could ever move
past that i'd be like really you're
making a lot of money off of my
amateur talents um and if
we are such amateurs then why are you
like why are you uh
i completely lost my train of thought
anyway i just think
uh the whole thing is pretty dumb the
the only unpaid
amateur sport i support is the great
british bake off
for me yeah i would say american ninja
warrior but yeah
i am with you with a great british bake
off but ever since
mary berry and melon sue left
i can't get behind it as well i can't
get behind it as much
wow um yeah i mean i will say as someone
who doesn't watch great british bake off
i apologize and i'm sure everything
you're saying is good and i agree
um but the complicated thing with
college sports then ends up being this
case where
you know if you were let's say a men's
basketball player at the university of
kentucky which is like a
historically famous program maybe you're
there and you
if they're gonna pay you your fair share
of the advertising money
tickets merch whatever you're gonna get
a big chunk of change
but let's say you play lacrosse at a
division three college in iowa
no one's going to your games you're not
on tv or whatever
so it creates this sort of like
inequality i guess where
some athletes could be getting paid at
professional levels some might not get
anything
so that does i mean this is like devil's
advocating advocating it a little bit
and this is why i still think it'd be
better
if these teams just became privatized we
could keep them in the same places like
take the florida state seminoles and
just make them the like
tallahassee amateur football team or
something but you know those are some of
the arguments that get used against this
sometimes it'll
be just distribute the money like you
know
every player regardless of what they're
playing
if that's your problem if it's unfair
give the lacrosse money some football
money
give the lacrosse team some football
money from each player according to
their abilities
to each player according to their needs
i don't know maybe
when is the ncaa like leading the charge
and like equal pay and [ __ ] no they're
not like
why don't you [ __ ] come work in
business and like do something
worthwhile
because if that's the argument and the
prevailing sentiment is like oh it's not
fair
it's like oh really where the [ __ ] have
you been for the last hundred years
like why aren't you come helping me with
my [ __ ] pay
i'm 50 grand underpaid come help me
yeah um i would love to hear if anyone
who listens to us
is a former college athlete would love
to hear your thoughts on this so if you
are listening right now well and
we'll tell you how you get in touch with
us in a little bit so keep listening or
if you
appreciate the amateurism i need to know
i i just i just want to hear all about
it like i only like things people are
unpaid
i want my food made by unpaid labor or
my sports to be
unpaid i want my bus drivers to make
that's not true to be clear yeah um well
we'll see what happens with this one
it's
it's it is interesting that like the
this is one of the few things our
supreme court could agree on these days
it's very interesting that this is one
of the things that gets unanimous vote
yeah um
we'll see um so we'll close off on a
real white topic
um critical race theory
um the reason i kind of want to talk
about this is
uh you know i'll put our cards on the
table where we're maybe working on doing
something
for the channel that has to do with this
topic so i've been reading about it and
listening to some podcasts and watching
some really weird youtube videos
the deal with this topic and for most of
us i don't know about y'all
until i don't know maybe
six seven months ago i wasn't really
aware of the term critical race theory
um would you say i i was but only
because like
i studied a lot of philosophy like it
came up in debate but it was always
it was always peripheral so it was very
strange to me because it's like
oh i've heard of this one author that
like a couple people i know are super
into you know these authors who write
about these things but
uh the idea that they're sort of
overtaking america is like nah that's
stupid
yeah i mean the only reason i really
knew about anything is i knew um that
earl sweatshirt
the really talented hip-hop artist mom
is one of the
um main figures behind wait sorry who
you've told me this but who is it
and now i feel very bad that i'm
forgetting her name which is horrible
because she's one of the the key
scholars around this it'll hit me in a
second
um oh cheryl harris so cheryl harris is
professor at ucla
um and she's the the mother of hip-hop
artist earl sweatshirt
um very you know famous and well-known
in her own right and makes sense of why
her son makes really interesting smart
music because he grew up in such an
interesting household but
it's it's one of those things where like
i've assumed as soon as i heard it i was
like i assume that
sorry frog in my throat and i assume i
get what this is
i know what critical theory is so i can
assume that i know what critical race
theory is like taking the methodologies
of critical theory to bear on thinking
about race
but it's blown up and it largely blew up
in the public discourse after the new
york times started their 1619 project
and then president donald j trump
started a 1776 commission to combat it
which put together a group of
non-historical scholars to argue
um for the the pure goodness of america
and i think
initially a lot of people took both the
1619 project
and this notion of critical race theory
as an affront
to the history of this country something
that is like pure and good
so it's become a sort of catch-all
phrase recently
not for the actual legal methodology and
it's its own purpose
but for the idea that ideas adjacent to
this
or ideas as far-ranging as like feminism
marxism anti-racism white supremacy all
of these things are now lumped into this
thing called
critical race theory such that it's now
officially been banned and banned in
terms of being able to be taught in
public schools
in eight u.s states with nine other
states in the process of doing so
so we're getting to a point where a
third of american states will have a
formal ban
on the teaching of critical race theory
so i want to talk a little bit about
like
what it is um the culture around this
right now and then we can i want to hear
what y'all think about this you know
it's and just to be clear if you're
listening to this right now
it's like a big topic there's a lot of
sides to this but let's just get the
ball rolling um
no critical race theory started in the
80s by some legal scholars many of whom
were like
grad students and i'm going to be kind
of casual with this i'm not reading off
anything but
um there were grad students at harvard
professor they liked a lot
leaves because he's like this place is
kind of racist i don't really like this
they start their own little crew they
start a conference they start getting
together and rethinking what it means to
approach legal theory um from the
perspective of being like
legal scholars and lawyers of color how
they're combating racism within
their field and thinking about it in
sort of systematic ways now they're
influenced by
critical theory critical theory comes
out of the frankfurt school
and it's a bunch of like philosophers
sociologists
theorists who are using philosophy and
philosophy and social theory
to examine society not in terms of
individual beliefs or desires
but societal and cultural structures
meaning that like
if if we're going to say that like billy
is racist
the question isn't why does billy feel
racism in his heart
it's what are the structures in his life
and education that have led billy down a
path where he's become
uh sort of interpolated as this like
racist subject
um so that's kind of like the framework
of critical theory they take that into
looking at
the law so critical race theory in
general had nothing to do with like
teaching children that thomas jefferson
was bad although he is
and was um it has to do with looking
at the law on our theory of rights in
america
and the way in which many laws
participate in these structures that
perpetuate bad
things now for the critical
critical race theorists you know for
them racism isn't like
a bad vibe you have in your heart it's a
systematic and institutional thing it's
not about individual feelings beliefs
and preferences
also they argue that race is a socially
constructed identity because of course
they point out some literature there
um when uh you know enslaved humans came
over from africa
there was no category of like these are
black people it's people from diverse
cultures speaking tons of different
languages from lots of different areas
but they get conflated into this one
social category
by the people um you know by white
people that
were running plantations stuff like that
in america so it's kind of like the
the general framework there but now um
it's being banned in schools the the fun
thing is i looked up a texas
tribune article talking about this and
they interviewed some teachers and i
found this very funny so this is
it's not funny that it's getting like a
band at the state level that's very
problematic and weird
but it's funny some of these teachers
responded on how they responded so
andrew robinson who is an 8th grade u.s
history teacher said
nobody in k12 is teaching critical race
theory if i tried to walk in and teach
critical race theory my kids
just have a blank stare on their face um
i don't think he's like dissing it he's
simply saying like this
isn't a part of like the what we teach
in history class
um someone else said critical race
theory is just not being taught in
schools
um someone else this is uh keflam brown
who teaches at ut
austin said a vast majority of teachers
in k-12 schools don't know critical race
theory they're not coming into the
classroom and saying
i'm going to teach critical race theory
um so it
creates this interesting question like
why are we stopping this thing in
schools that's not being taught in
schools
why do people want to clamp down on the
teaching of a thing that's not taught
and what does that
really mean um
last thing oh sorry go ahead alex i was
going to say um i was speaking to a
teacher from florida where
uh governor desantis similar order i was
like
you know this is this one this is an
anecdote uh this is one
teacher's sort of experience but it's
like what does it actually mean
right because you know you're not going
around teaching kimberly crenshaw
or derek bell or any of these people um
and
she was basically like it's super vague
and basically it means that
uh if i say the wrong thing and offend
the like wrong kid
they're gonna complain to their kid
their parents and then like i'm gonna
get fired
um and i i think that's part of the scam
is that it is if you want to
if you want to criticize the work of
kimberly crenshaw like
go ahead there are certainly criticisms
of it but basically people have made it
so amorphous to be like
well you said that racism is bad and you
said that like slavery was bad so that's
critical race theory
um so basically like i feel like you
know talk about free speech like a bunch
of teachers are gonna sit around being
like
ooh like is it okay to mention that you
know thomas jefferson did medical
experiments on his slaves
that might be critical race theory
someone might complain about it
yeah i mean i think of it like with the
school example it's almost like if my
son
chadwick iii is in class i guess the
fear is that like
the teacher will teach about the history
of
racism white supremacy all these
structural things in america then my son
chadwick will feel bad about himself and
chadwick will think
oh no am i bad for being white and
a lot of the critical race theorists
don't want chadwick to feel bad
the irony of course is that the entire
framework of critical race theory isn't
to say
that chadwick should feel bad about
himself
it should be that chadwick is
unconsciously participating in systems
that
predate his conception that have shaped
the way our society and culture and
legal system works
and we can think about those things
critically
so chadwick my golden boy is not like
a klansman now it's just that uh he
might be
unaware of the privileges afforded to
him as being a
white in in the current system or
something like that but it seems like
the fear is that he he cries
and comes home and i call the school and
say how dare you yeah it's amazing to me
the
lengths we'll go to to prevent a white
person from feeling uncomfortable but
people
of color they can just
kick rocks what is also so like
perversely [ __ ] up about this
as critical race theory as a it's about
the systems it's again not about like uh
oh you have hatred in your heart it's
like hey we have all these laws
the way our courts work the way
prosecutors work they're all supremely
[ __ ] up
and like you can feel bad you could go
to a diversity training but that's not
going to fix this [ __ ] like we need to
like change laws change your legal
structure etc
um i was reading uh there's a great new
yorker article
about this guy who basically popularized
among conservatives
called christopher ruffo um
but basically he was reading like robin
d'angelo
uh what's her book called how to be
oh white fragility white fragility yeah
like he read some of these sort of like
you know very sort of corporate friendly
like anti-racist things
um and noticed like in one of the the
the footnotes there was like reference
to kimberly crenshaw one of these
critical race theorists
and he's like oh is this the secret
behind it
but people like can really crunch on
this article makes a comment like
hey i think a lot of what these like
diversity trainings are doing is like
not what i would do or not what my work
stands for like
uh you know not that she's categorically
opposed to them but
uh yeah it's a it's a weird conflation
that basically has come to mean anything
that i don't like yeah i mean the
conflation thing is real i think it
it gets used to describe um anything
that implies or points out
systematic racism in the foundational
history of the country
it's used to crit to criticize anything
that's
critical of capitalism anything that
calls the dominant system into question
is now critical race theory incredible
it's like it's like post-modern
neo-marxism it's like basically like
cultural bolshevism which was the nazi
term and i'm not saying all these people
are nazis but i think these sort of
pokemon and it weirdly like i remember
there's
this one gun beck episode where he like
had this board about like why feminism
was marxist or something and like it all
went to like angela davis and herbert
marcusa
and in this article about rufo it's
basically the same thing as like
well you know herbert marcusa was a
marxist and he taught angela davis and
she was a feminist so therefore
well marcus came up um so one of the
people who sort of like
the quote unquote intellectual figures
around this is james lindsay who has a
phd in mathematics
mathematics not humanity's not sociology
not literature not philosophy not legal
studies um
and he runs a website called new
discourses i shouldn't even say the name
because i don't think you should go to
it but
um he's been speaking about this and
writing about this he likes to throw
around like words like marcusa and
marxist
um recently he did an uh segment on mark
lamont hill's
youtube show where he talked about this
and it's very fun at the end
lamont hill who who's like a legit
humanities and politics scholar
kind of owns him at the end by showing
he doesn't have any idea what he's
talking about when he says marxism
because marxism like
for many of these people and to be clear
i'm not saying marxism is good
or bad i'm just saying it means a thing
and there's a history behind that word
and a series of concepts that go with
that
and they're just throwing it around to
mean like i don't know like your kid
gets put in a camp or something
and the same guy lindsey and i'm not
done with this yet he did a
four-hour podcast about hegel
and how um 19th century german ideals
philosopher
um george wilheim friedrich hegel is at
the heart of what he calls
critical race theory and wokism in
america
and how it can all be traced back to
that um i've listened a little bit so
far and it made me want to rip my
eyeballs out and show
them you know what about hagel would you
would you consider him a woke
philosopher
no i mean he's definitely not the heart
of this and if anything hegel's is
someone who like
thinks about concepts that's all he
cares about is the conceptual
framework for our thinking so you could
say that something's a gaelian it just
means
you're thinking about it in a certain
critical way ridiculous
um but i'm going to keep listening to
that podcast because i want to do stuff
um but i'd say the final thing i find
great about this is so much of it boils
down to this
that critical race theory is racist
against white people
and that is another thing you will see
in a lot of the discourse
and the literature which once again is
funny because critical race theory
itself talks about how race is a
socially constructed category
so to say that you're racist against
white people essentializes this thing
called whiteness in a way
uh that would be against that structural
analysis anyways but yeah i just
i don't know i'm trying to be like open
and stuff i don't even know what that
means
to be racist against white people
thoughts and prayers for white people
yeah i mean i think the other part of
the scam is like to talk about racism's
critical race theory
to talk about racist critical race
theory but actually
because because talking about race means
critical race theory if you say the word
white therefore it's racist which which
like as a as a framing of a thing you
can't
if you're talking about slavery it's
like well who who enslaved africans is
like well you know you can't say you
can't say white people because that
that's racist
you know like those particular people
yeah it was particularly
from europe or like what kind of parents
were you know boycotting
school integration or i i don't know uh
you know
who who has like money you know
generation through generation from slave
henches i i i i can't tell you anything
it's
sorry that their grandparents worked
hard alex yeah um
yeah i mean i will say with all this
like and i mean this generally if you're
some this is a part of the discourse
there's a lot of people that are using
very flashy arguments to get at this
um you know i would just say that a lot
of
the critical theory aspect of this
critical theory isn't some like
hella ideological way of thinking about
stuff it's a way of just
critically thinking about society if you
listen to this podcast and you like
wisecrack stuff you at least have to
have some appreciation
of philosophical thinking and socratic
method and approaching things
with an open mind and being willing to
criticize society um you know this goes
all the way back to a bunch of old dead
white guys in athens so
you know what the critical race
theorists are trying to do as far as i
understand it i'm not a legal scholar
is just take a method of you know kind
of like presuppositionless critical
thinking
to bear on the legal structures in our
society
it's it's it's a very reasonable thing
to do
it's a thing that if you've studied
philosophy or sociology should not
surprise you at all and if anything
should just seem kind of like yeah why
wouldn't they do that yeah this is like
normal stuff
philosophy's not about asking questions
michael oh i forgot but i would say that
like that's the thing that makes me
nervous about this in general entering
the discourse
is the way in which it is sort of
against
asking the questions that are
fundamental to the humanities and social
sciences
many of those questions which presuppose
that the world isn't the way it is
because of any pre-ordained goodness
but because humans have constructed
things in a certain way and because
humans have constructed them a certain
way we can criticize those constructions
but i don't know um any other thoughts
on
critical race theory um i feel like i
have a lot more empathy now for
the struggles of uh the white man
you know my work here is done josh in
the chat i wonder if old dead greeks
thought they were white i think the
answer is no
because the concept of whiteness
basically formed around
like the french and english hated each
other so much it was
very hard for them to come together and
realize that they were like the same
group of people
until they were afraid of slave revolts
yeah like well we should all get
together
so we don't get murdered by our slaves
yeah i mean whiteness at one point
literally meant like
descendants of the mayflower and then
slowly started to incorporate like you
know
the scots or the irish or the germans
the italians real late in the game you
know
greeks late in the game so yeah i don't
really think they
thought about that but also the greeks
like you know day drank and cuddled with
13 year old boys let's not have them be
our idols
sorry hey everyone plato's symposium
check it out
read it um get uncomfortable so now that
we've said all that we want to hear what
you have to think about all of these
things we threw a lot at you today um
you know we're talking about we got into
work culture pretty deeply we got into
college athletics and we got into
critical race theory
and we want to hear you have to say so
get in touch with us there's two ways
you can do that one
you email us at culturebinge wisecrack
dot co co no m leave them alone
call your binge wisecrack.com or give us
a call at 213-534-8807 that is
213-534-8807 um alec do we have anything
in the magical mailbag this week
yeah uh i want to read two emails uh
thanks for everyone for sending them in
uh the first one's from robert hey
hertzerby says she's watching a show
that's what if the norse gods were alive
today and want a recommendation for
another show we'll have to see it
well i happen to know of a show called
the almighty johnsons here in new
zealand that is what if the norse gods
were live in new zealand today
so if you can find it online find it
online check it out and see if it has
interesting parallels
thank you robert that's so great thank
you so much for recommending that
i am a huge fan of new zealand and your
prime minister
uh so i'm looking forward to checking
out your show i hate new zealand
uh so the next email is from michael
good name no there's only room for one
mic now i'm kidding
i'll change it uh i wanted to write to
you about your discussion of naomi asaka
uh stance on mental health and press
conferences i think it's a situation
that reflects an
interesting tension in how we discuss
these types of issues namely that so
often we have to discuss them with a
celebrity as the focal point
i thought this recent piece in the
guardian really summarized it well
celebrities high profile figures and
influencers have a contradictory impact
they have a wide reach but their wealth
seems to be incongruent with the pain
they are trying to highlight
you couldn't if you tried find less
sympathetic ambassadors for the
pain caused by racism or poor mental
health and pop stars
royalty in the world's elite athletes it
becomes easy then to cast their
complaints as tantrums rather than cries
for help uh
that's the quote then uh michael goes on
to say naomi asaka made an estimated 55
million dollars in
2020 2021 that's more money than most of
us will make in our entire lives and
she's 23 years old after doing some
quick math her fifteen thousand dollar
fine is the equivalent
of sixteen dollars for someone on the
average american annual wage does any of
this make
naomi osaka immune to the issues that
can affect mental health of course not
however i think
people look at the context and find it
muddies the waters when discussing a
subject stance that most people will
probably find inoffensive a non-issue
i.e that mental health is important and
should be respected i absolutely agree
with many of your comments michael's
point that press is part of
what enables professional the
professional game is true and i love
your suggestion that the format should
be mixed up or possibly providing
players a more positive incentive to get
involved with the press
here's hoping some of that can be
implemented anyway thanks for everything
you guys do it really brightens my week
to hear the three smart people discuss
stuff with nuance and good humor i think
it's a great perspective what do you
think that's great
thanks for writing in brightens my day
when someone like you writes in
i appreciate the hell out of it i i do i
think it's double
i think some people are like [ __ ]
celebrities why would i be sympathetic
to this
at the same time i've seen people in my
own personal lives
get over certain prejudices basically
instantaneously because of this thing a
celebrity did
um i had mentioned someone i know
they're very pro like gay rights before
marriage equality back in the day
whatever they're always like being
bisexual is not cool which is a [ __ ]
up opinion
but then i was like hey this this friend
of mine is actually bisexual don't be an
[ __ ]
this person just looked at me as like oh
well you know angelina jolie
used to date women before she married
so-and-so so it must be okay and i was
like all right like that's how you got
there good for you
so thank you angelina jolie for you know
dating men and women so
people in my life could be on board with
it wow
i mean i think the theme of everything
today is just like thank you so much
angelina jolie i do
really the theme is thank you so much to
white people
sergey said that no one else said that
alec and i are both shaking our heads
furiously
do not cancel us um cool fact about
angelina jolie is that she does her own
shopping
at uh a silver lake sorry the silver
like trader joe's i shouldn't have said
that because now i can go
i've seen her there and i was there with
jacob and he was trying to sell the
company
i was like alec go over there look at
angelina jolie i was like i'm not gonna
do that jacob
yeah but that's kind of chill and i
think wizard no one's gonna go up and
talk to angelina jolie she's scary i
don't mean that in a good way she's
probably she looks
she looks powerful and scary powerful
bisexual woman
actor mother producer scholar activist
hero
i will this wasn't an email but i do
want to shout out um
someone on the youtube comments now
don't make
this think that you should leave
comments and we're going to read them
don't let me don't let this get in your
heads but
hero of kush said that if we were all
substances
serbia's wine so that's a nice classy
you know some you have it nice occasions
alec is weed it's just a chill
bro you want to like watch him anime
with and
michael is probably coke if not at least
coffee
something to give you an energy boost
than a crash
i don't know i think i disagree with
cocaine i agree with the other two i say
crack
wow um i'm thinking like mdma i don't
know
i i would think more of an mdma i'll and
i'll tell you why because
i get like the up energy weird thing i
get the crash thing
but it is more like positive vibes and
not like i'm gonna tell you about my
business plan
and i don't know if anyone who's
listening to this has friends to do
cocaine um they're not fun to be around
and they will talk to you about the most
inane [ __ ] and it sucks
whereas if you're around a friend on
mdma they might like earnestly
share feelings with you they haven't
been able to express because of like
unconscious or conscious anxiety
and it'll be a really good experience um
but like don't do drugs or do drugs
i don't know make your own decisions
you're all adults
sorry about that but someone started but
let us know what you think about us
um and please do call email
534807. that was all the emails right
alec yep
awesome um so if someone doesn't want to
call our email
where can they find us on the social
media serbia where are you
siripatel22 on twitter tweet me yeah
but be but be cool don't tweet her and
be weird be cool
any people are seem to be pretty normal
to me i'm gonna say this why is greg
fans on twitter
rule i only have like really cool
interactions with uh
our fans on twitter so keep it up um
alec where can i find you
i'm at wisecrack out on twitter cool and
i'm
at michael o'burns uh we will be back in
two weeks with another culture binge
thanks for hanging out like review
subscribe in the meantime and we will
see you
then bye guys
[Music]
you